*UH YAHSYDHAYDG* (what I say will be in brackets)
Subtitles after ad
It's time for me to flex on you kids
I got a brand new Origin PC
I have no idea what's inside it,
but based on the gamer lights aesthetic, I can tell it's pretty damn powerful
ha-tat-tat-ta (I have no idea what he is doing... but i think he means "stop/wait")
Look at this.
*Shilling Intensifies...ALOT*
How is this not the greatest computer ever made?
With this, I can finally destroy T-Series(More like L-series)
But this is not just it...
You guys can win one of these as well :O
and you can customize your case as well
if the Brofist aesthetic isn't your taste
I respect it
even though you're 100% wrong
This model is called the Neuron
Origin PC is the only custom PC company
to have their own line of exclusive desktop cases
like this Neuron case
Because these cases have magnetic feet so..
Just like my Chronos
You can lay it horizontally
or vertically
So it can do this (ancient gaming chair joke inbound)
and
it can do this (͠≖ ͜ʖ͠≖)
*WOAH*
It has an Intel Core i9-9900K 8-Core 3.60 GHz 5.00 Max Turbo *WOAH*(again)
and a Single 11Gb NVIDIA GeForce RTX 2080 Ti Founder's Edition
That's right
*Just read the text on the screen dammit* (CC person 2 here, I agree with CC person 1) (CC person 3 here, i agree with CC person 2.)(CC person 4 here subscribe to pewdiepie)(CC person 5 here unsub from T-Series)
I don't know what any of this means, (it means fire and half of the framerate with RTX)
but I 100% need it
So I can record myself
Watching memes
Origin PC also comes with
24/7, 365 day a year Lifetime Tech Support
For free on all of their PC's (will be needed for that RTX fire)
Right now they have a black Friday sale
and cyber Monday sale
Where you can get up to $850 in value
Right now they have offers like:
An Origin gaming laptop starting at $1,299 (USD) with free ground shipping
And much more
Check it out!
Thank you Origin for sponsoring this video
and thank you for this amazing computer [END OF AD SEGMENT] (pewds needs the damn money, Youtube ads are filled with tik tok and T Garbage okay?)
Well, let's just jump into it
Let's get on with the video
In my battle against T-Series
Two of my fellow closest Youtube brethren
Jacksepticeye (Jackspedicey)
Markiplier (red Pewdiepie)
have remained silent *minecraft_oof.wav*
So, therefore, I have picked two new friends to help me out!
Hello!
Welcome!
that's right
I totally didn't pay you guys
*Everyone Laughs*
Welcome PewDiePie clone
(Roomie) (AKA Swedish Chris Pine)
Thats me
And male feminist
(Boyinaband)
*everyone laughs*
Ok, this is Joel (right) and Dave (left)
Both: Hi
And we're gonna
We're gonna review some
reddit stuff
*Everyone Laughs*
Dave: I'm not used to this at all
So sorry
Pewds: Can you feel the cringe?
Why do I look so goddamn short?
What is this?
Everyone keeps saying I'm short
but this is not true (lies)
Dave: Yeah, if you want to make Felix feel really uncomfortable
Point it out
Pewds: *Laughs*
Joel: You should see the shoes Felix wears everyday
They're like this big
Dave: Proper platforms
Pewds: They're not that big
*Everyone laughs*
We're- You're here for Reddit and nothing else
Joel: Yea quit your bulls**t
Pewds: Yea, spoilers!
We're reviewing the LWIAY subreddit
*Awkward silence*
Just kidding, we're doing quit your bulls**t
Dave: Is it Brad or Sive editing this?
Pewds: Uh, I don't know
Dave: Ok
Pewds: Why?
Dave: They're gonna have to censor out the word every time
We're gonna have to come up with something other than-
Pewds: No they'll censor it
*Everyone Laughs*
Don't try to make it easier for them
What are you doing?
Dave: Sorry
Hey! Look, guys
Look what it says
look what it is
look Swedish boys (It's actually the Dover boys)
Pewds: This is a very important quit your bulls**t for me (D e m o n i t i z e d)
and, for you as well I assume
Joel: *I genuinely have no idea what he just said* (CC Person 2 here: this is Swedish) (CC Person 4 here: He just said ''I love IKEA'' in Swedish. )
*chuckles* Me too
*Pewds is reading the text above the image*
*Dave reading the comment*
Why? (Cause.....'Merica.....F' yeah?)
*Joel is reading IKEA's response* (Rule 1: never respond to internet comments)
Pewds: I have no idea what's happening
Dave: Like, the United States clearly has a code that shows the specific height at which their flag should be shown in comparison to other flags
and IKEA happened to be able to reel it off immediately.
...That's...
Dave: That's pretty good
Pewds: Quit your bulls**t IKEA
I mean- uh- United States ヽ(°〇°)ﾉ
Dave: *reads title* Delivering the twist ending
*Pewds reading tweet*
*Dave reading other tweet*
Pewds: Why would they post that?
Dave: Right! How does that even happen?
Pewds: How do you get that wrong?
Dave: *quietly* Who's John Carpenter (Blasphemy!)
Pewds: He's a legendary horror movie maker
Pewds: uhhhhh
Dave: *reading Wikipedia entry* Halloween
Pewds: Did he do Halloween? The Thing. Halloween. Yeah, The Fog. Yeah, yeah.
Pewds: Its got 70 thousand up votes it has to be good
Dave: *quietly* That's how Reddit works
Pewds: That's how Reddit works *laughs*
Joel: *reads comment displayed above*
Joel: that's good should I do it again?
Pewds: That's how it was written out
Dave: Yeah it was
Joel: Yeah
Joel: Should I do that again, maybe?
Pewds: nah it was perfect, we don't do other takes here *everyone laughs*
Dave: *reads comment displayed above*
*everyone laughs*
Pewds: you're just a hater quit your bullsh**
Dave: "Your phone is now hacked"
(CC person 3: Alright.....no one translated the whole thing so....)
*Dave reads the text above*
Joel: "What kind of phone am I on, what OS?"
Dave: "You have 30 seconds to send them before I destroy it"
Joel: "You didn't answer my que-"
Dave: "I don't need to"
*Everyone laughs*
Joel: "it's been more than 30 sec-
Dave: "Yup it's getting destroyed"
Joel: "You didn't really plan ahea-
Dave: "Yes, I just destroy it, you think I can't?"
Joel: "I'm still waiting on that"...
"Look I'm gonna go get some lunch, you have fun with hacking my ph-"
Dave: "Just copying all your content from it first"
Joel: "Ok sure"...
"You done yet?"...
"I mean it can't take that long, I only have like 4 pictures on my phone and they're all of pigeons"
Pewds: What the F***
Dave: What?
Pewds: I wanna see the pigeons...
Have you guys ever gotten anyone like that?
Dave: Uhhh... I don't think I've had anyone claiming to hack my phone through a DM
Joel: I think- I think I've been that guy.
Pewds: What?
Dave: What?
Joel: Like, as a meme I thought it was funny
Joel: Like, when facebook was new,
You'd like, DM people and be like "it's not me, it's someone else".
Dave: You'd do that?!
Pewds: You were an epic troll dude.
*Everyone laughs*
Joel: Have you told your story on your channel about when you used to steal sh*t?
Joel: You have, right?
Pewds: Next!
*Everyone laughs*
*Pewds is reading the text above.*
*Joel is reading the comment*
*Joel continues reading* "when I said hi to you at the carnival. Good times. lol.
Dave:That "lol" is spectacular
Pewds:"fat little F****** B****
*more giggles*
What happened at the carnival?
Dave: Which of those is the most offensive?
Like...
Pewds: "little"
Dave: The little, I think, is what hits me the most...
Pewds: You Just gotta spread positivity...
Dave: Also... *reads the comment from "when"*
Pewds: "Hey! How are you doing?"         |･ω･)ﾉ
"L I T T L E    F * * * * *   B * * * *"                    |ʘ‿ʘ)ﾉ
You can't....You can't say that word...
Dave: I thought that you said they (Brad and Brad 2) were gonna blur-blur- *quietly, with confusion* blur it?
(CC person 3. out....maybe someone will continue translating that.) (CC person 5, *thumbs up*)
*giggles* They're gonna blur the word?
Pewds: Are you tryna make it harder for my poor hardworking employees?!
*maniacal laughter ensues*
Joel: Hey, turn this around (???)
Pewds: OK, so...
*Pewds is reading the text above*
*Dave sighs then reads the text*
Pewds: Jesus Christ
Joel: This is the wordiest thing ever
Pewds: But, I do think it's interesting though, like-
Dave: Yeah, yeah. I- I love when people just pull that kind of thing out
NASA is not that stupid
Pewds: Right
Dave: It's freaken NASA
There's been several studies that show that NASA
has made way more money than was invested into it
Pewds: Really?
Dave: From all the things that have been invented from it
Dave: *enthusiastically* Baby formula came from NASA
Pewds: What's baby formula?
Dave: *incredulously* The stuff that they give to babies...
Pewds: Why are they showing me a computer mouse? (instead of a picture of baby formula)
Dave: *giggles* I don't know
Pewds: Oh, that's number two...
Dave: Oh, okay
Pewds: They invented the compu-(ter mouse)???
Dave: Oh, right
Pewds: What??
Joel: That's dope
Dave: So NASA made the mouse?
Pewds: *loudly* OHMAGAWD the shoes you're wearing!
Joel: OH MY- my comfortable running shoes!
*Everyone Laughs*
Pewds: Thanks NASA!
Dave: *mimics Pewds* Thanks NASA!
Pewds: Your comfortable running shoes
Dave: Cell phone cameras
Pewds: Okay that's pretty epic...
I don't know if I'm thankful for that, actually
Dave: *does a big chuckle* Yeah NASA invented selfies, cheers
Pewds: Safer highways!? There's no way NASA did that, right- quit your bull**it
*Everyone gives Pewds a pity laugh for the callback*
Joel: *menacingly* QUIT YOUR BULL**IT
Dave: Oh, we've got a nice little "Musk" one here
Pewds: Alright... Musky one...
Dave: You can play Elon Musk
Pewds: Okay, thank you
*Dave reads the headline*
Pewds: WOW, this is false
Dave: *sniff* that's so on the nose
Pewds: Complex, what are you doin'?
*pewds reads the text the cursor is hovering over
*sharp inhale* Yeah I don't do that...
*the gang has a hefty chuckle over that joke*
*Joel reads the Reddit entry*
Pewds: Ask me anything...
*Dave reads the first reply on the thread*
*Pewds reads the second reply*
What a savage mom, Rory's mom, like imagine being called out like that
Joel: Yeah
Dave: Do ya reckon he just did that intentionally
Dave: To make a meme out of himself
Detective Joel: How would the mom, like, see that immediately and then, like...
Pewds: Yeah, I don't see...
Joel: Yeah
Dave: Quit your bull**it, "r/quityourbull**it"
Pewds: *chuckles*
*Pewds reads the Twitter post*
*Dave reads the reply*
*another hefty chuckle emanates from everyone*
Pewds: JUST GO
Dave: Augh, that's something that really bothers me
The whole, "I need an excuse to post this selfie that makes me seem like I'm a victim"
Pewds: Do you guys remember when selfies were frowned upon?
*chuckles all around*
Do you remember?
Dave: *backwoods grandpa voice* Back in the day, when I was a ki-(trails off indecipherably)
Joel: Do you remember when uploading videos was frowned upon?
Pewds: Oh that was weird yeah...
Joel: Like, anything weird with your friends
Like, that was like when, I think, you and I started
Pewds: Yeah
Dave: Really?
Joel: It was like- (new thought) and now like,
I see all my friends like, uploading like, all this sh*t to like, Facebook and Instagram and stuff
It's like everyone is doing it
Pewds: Yeah
Joel: It's like, weird how it became so mainstream
Pewds: We fought through the stigma
*this garners a big chuckle from Dave*
Joel: YAASs
Pewds: And here we are
Pewds: Two empowered Swedish boys
Joel: Yee (???)
Dave: *with aversion* Oh my GOd...
*Joel reads the begnning of the Reddit thread in a Swedish accent(?)*
Dave: That's crazy...
Pewds: *continues in Swedish accent, annunciating* Dam-neh...
*huge outburst of laughter especially from Joel*
*throat squeaking*
Pewds: *continuing* glad you're NOT still here OP. (contrary to the text on screen)
Dave: Clearly, glad you're STILL here...
Joel: Yeah
Pewds: OH, glad you're-
*uproarious laughter*
Joel: Glad you're dead OP!!!
Pewds: I can't read...
Dave: Is that what Swedish people are like???
Pewds: You-
Dave: I'm glad you're dead!!
*big laffs from the crew*
Pewds: Yeah!
*laffs continue*
*inhale*
*Pewds corrects himself and reads the reply flawlessly*
*Dave reads next reply*
*Joel reads the following reply*
*Dave begins reading the next reply*
*Pewds reads the next reply in a weird Swedish accent*
*chuckles and inhales*
*Dave reads this next reply like a rad surfer dude*
Pewds: Yeah, quit your bull**it, man
Joel: *thique Swedish accent* Quit your bull**it
*Pewds and Joel saying "quit your bull**it" with varying degrees of Swedish and English*
Pewds: Okay, this is a review from "Crepes And Cones"
Dave: Okay what kind of voice do you think...
This would be like...
Pewds: The voice of someone ordering a waffle
*Dave proceeds to begin reading the review as if there is something lodged in his throat*
*everyone does a quick giggle*
*Dave restarts reading the review with the same funny voice*
*Pewds and Joel giggle about how Dave reads the word "shocking"*
*Joel starts reading the owner's response in the same voice that Dave was using to read the review*
Pewds: Why would you write that?
Dave: Maybe it's just someone who hates that person
Pewds: Do you guys ever write reviews... *he trails off at the end*
Dave: Oh right! Maybe we can check out some of your reviews!
Joel: OOHHHHHH YES *clap*
Dave: Yeah Felix (Pewds) is a guy who actually writes reviews for things
Pewds: I dunno why you guys think that's so weird!
Joel: It's hilarious
Dave: I don't know anyone else who writes reviews
Pewds: I'm doing them a favour!
Dave: I know!
Joel: It's just that, like, you're public like, you're like, it's just, you're like a public online person
And you're doing reviews in your own name
And like, it's really funny
"Felix Kjellberg thinks the pizza here is alright!"
*everyone has a chuckle*
Dave: It was harsh, some of it
Joel: Oh yeah, some of it was really mean
Pewds: If they're sh*t they need to know!
How can they improve
*Dave reads this Pewds-Review*
Joel: That's so funny
Dave: Jesus
What made you so angry at this place that that was your
*pause*
Pewds: hmm
They were actually lovely in there!
Dave: *chokes*
Pewds: To be frank (?)
Dave: But that's- that's lovely??
Pewds: I- I almost, I almost wrote like
"but the staff was good"
but, I was like, eh, you know what...
Dave: You reviewed Nando's?!
Joel: AHhhh-ha-ha
Dave: People don't know what Nando's is?
Pewds: They need my review!
The people need-
Dave: The small up-and-coming business Nando's needs the endorsement of Pewdiepie™
Joel: That's hilarious
To get by-
Pewds: Hey I got free food at Nando's once... because of it...
Pewds: Hey another waffle one *reads the tweet*
*Joel reads Waffle House's reply*
Pewds: DAMMNN  x2
*chorus of weird noises from everyone, "AGH" "OH" "DAMN" "AH"*
Pewds: Waffle House go away! Oh! (lol)
Okay, hope you enjoyed this Reddit video,
Check out Joel (RoomieOfficial) and Dave's (Boyinaband) channel, link in description!
They make videos once every, while...
Dave: heh, it's been like four months...
Joel: I have a video out today!
Dave: Oh?
Joel: Yeah.
Pewds: Check out the "daily" video
*some chuckles from everyone present*
Joel: It's been two months, but I really(?) did it today
Pewds: And that's it. Goodbye.
Alright, Dave, you can leave now
Joel: Do you wanna get waffles?
Pewds: Later, yeah let's get some waffles, yeah, sounds good.
subtitles by spider sim....ok bye :D